[Aplausos]
[Música]
foi no estádio hoje
[Aplausos]
porque somos dois bairros tem a ver
necessariamente com o tema não é porque
como é que não é difícil ser feliz
ligando também com grande tema desde
verso porto que é a primavera não
s-class renovação não é difícil ser
feliz sobretudo na primavera
nós somos dois porque não para negar é
por um lado a nossa matriz científica e
de investigação e não para negar a
existência real e concreta de
funcionários em visuais mas já sobre
todos os dois com estoque symbol e de
sociedades pelo menos em dueto tem muito
mais consequências dessas consequências
são jorge
pensava como a história de uma mulher há
cerca de um ano atrás numa conversa
entre pais numa numa escola é que é
exatamente sobre como é que ficamos de
ser possível trocar o futebol felicidade
uma senhora levantou se uma jovem mulher
com sorriso link e disse eu vou contar
uma história pessoal quer preparar os
que ali alguns caros diz que há dois
anos atrás tinha am que num acidente de
automóvel em que ela aguiar e um bebê de
quatro meses um único que tinha esse
acidente o filho morreu e ela dizia que
naquele momento teve que seguir se ia
continuar assim feliz ou não o resto da
sua vida e que não tive dúvidas assim
que saiu do hospital com parada de que
tinha todas as razões para continuar a
viver a felicidade é o que tem
acontecido é que o dvd s terceira é que
os quatro meses não para de chorar em
vinhedo noite ela tem estado a preparar
colo uma marca carinho mimos tentar
encontrar alguma maneira de os seus
gastos
ela dizia que era observado há um ano
que tinha sido resultado
um ato de amor e por isso ela servia que
é enviada por que continuar com um
sentimento de felicidade é só com
simplicidade se não a mais que o tipo de
sociedade ou mais neste mundo às vezes
também só para que poderia ter sido um
painel com o sono rem mesmo por temas e
não esqueça esse sentido negativo não é
fui ensinada depois alegria para
combinarem sexo desta edição que
interessa bastante felicidade
naturalmente não é um conceito novo os
gregos antigos eu gastei para a vitória
não é um dos grandes clássicos não é
novo mas muito sobretudo por via da
psicologia positiva não é um conceito
novo mas é inglês é sexy
o súbito da psicologia positiva como os
encontramos o 'gato' treinou esta estudo
científico da sociedade uma coisa 79 e
psicologia nas escolhas que estão
concorda comigo
nós temos um carro uma tendência um cara
extrema ou tornamos anoréxicas algumas
das funções alguns dos conceitos algumas
das idéias ou então em seus de tantos
sentidos decentes tão denso que eles
ficam mais ligado ao vezes mas eu acho
que essa idéia da possível de ser
superada ser revisitada de um ponto de
vista científico é uma coisa importante
que nos têm dado ó que diziam concepções
e incríveis como o manel eu também é
ótimo fazer castelão é um dos convivas
em concreto por aqui pronto depois eu
lembro ainda neste enquadramento da
felicidade do que temos nada a fazer na
sociedade do df que aí não é não não
produz o que pode fazer pela sociedade
pergunta o que é uma sociedade sobretudo
definida por outra em distante e
abstrata orgulho de tudo o que tu podes
fazer pela tua fun cidade individual ou
interpessoal
uma outra idéia é também aquela dos
dados científicos que história é essa
funcionalidade mas isso não é esse
medicamento terminado
é a senhora eo e vivência empírica
vai ficar uma forma conclui é o seguinte
pelo menos 50% da cidade é genética
determinava andará por volta dos dez por
cento é influência da experiência
passada ou seja em relação à 60% não há
muito que possamos fazer mas os outros
40% é mesmo uma diferença cet que nina
de 1 por cento na minha qualidade de
vida pode ser uma coisa em cascata e é
isso também que nos anima muito nesta
nesta empreendimento em que nos
encontramos ligados
o meu filho fernando dizia que em
algumas pessoas a alma enruga papel e
outras que esquece de avisar a cara que
estão contentes e nós achamos que
poderíamos conquistar um pouquinho
trazer aqui um a e e um da felicidade
revisitando a rússia samak pessoas que
se lembram ter prendido o visto
vocês vão com um ponto de partida para a
descoberta das vogais e quem sabe
exatamente com a autonomia saibam que
dois terços da nossa vida passada a
fazer coisas que nós não queremos fazer
o que não poderíamos fazer isso quer
dizer que seremos capazes de ver se é
com entusiasmo que precisamos criar as
condições presentes que temos liberdade
fixemos control sobre o nosso destino
político falava do amor fat
é daqui que ele ia matar faro vai falar
nos do fato e amor e mais romário
destino é preciso uma função para a
nossa geração que de fato levou as
muitas vezes e fazer coisas que preferia
não fazer duas soluções uma e outro
facto como os 20 que alguns sonhos
passarmos a fazer mais coisas escolher
mais nas nossas vidas coisas que
realmente queremos fazer outra e
naquelas que habitualmente fazemos o que
não temos oportunidade liberdades e que
não é passar estamos sem os nossos
objetivos pessoais imagine por exemplo
nos melhor lá em casa e no chão muito
tratamos muito em treinamento
trabalhamos 24 horas por dia juntos
trilhamos de noite e dia
há muitos anos é muito utilizado e
imaginem que ela é fã de lavar louça
jantar cinza que quer ser um melhor
marido possível aprovar a lei estabelece
objetivos muito concreto em todos os
detalhes de 11 movimentos da lavagem 2 a
1 o asa quer ver a torcida visava mas
pronto você vai ficar a manhã para ó
seja mesmo as coisas ambos sido as
devidas feitas com o objetivo tem esta
capacidade se tornará em pelo menos mais
leves pronto eu passava porém a da
autonomia já vi também durante todo o
dia muitos exemplos de carreiras de
vidas e experiências com autonomia o eu
gosto muito e gosto muito daqui e
escolhemos dá para entrar o ecc energia
psíquica a energia psíquica o entusiasmo
é o contrário da entre e psíquica eu
gosto desta desta não via consciências
de física embora entenda não não procura
usar vela energia psíquica é o que ele
dizia psíquica estar motivado para a
ação e e saber aceitar desafios
[Música]
prometo loman é você vai ficar com a
vaga
temos agora wii item a independência dos
muse à filhinho que não era o caso
estava nos 2 xíc trabalhamos juntos
também está de fato de pau vez que a
frase dizendo que a liberdade para a
felicidade pode ser um espaço para
adaptá la a se inspirar em vídeo a pode
ser paradoxal
de facto neste momento há muita
investigação científica dizer que a
cidade cresce nas relações e que essa é
talvez o maior objetivo que os seres
humanos vão vir a ter neste momento da
história da humanidade e voltar a fazer
aquilo que no fundo é nossa escuta todos
sabemos que cuidar das pessoas que
tenham solado cuidar das pessoas que
gostamos e capazes de perceber que
assumirá um isolamento é competitividade
o tentar apenas
e investir na felicidade individual
ministro tem mostrado nas últimas
décadas que não está em feito mais feliz
estamos com melhor qualidade de vida
indubitavelmente mas estudos mostram que
na melhor das hipóteses em termos de
bem-estar subjetivo mas estamos a
considerar os flashes em relação às
últimas décadas importantes vivemos
muito melhor
não estamos mais sentirmos mais fez e um
dos truques vai ser voltar a residir nas
relações das pessoas importantes na
nossa língua
ok a autonomia é de energia psíquica e
de interdependência o óbvio otimismo
nós há uns anos atrás quando éramos mais
novo fizemos uma coisa que eu escrever
um livro sobre o otimismo em 99 e foi
engraçado porque antecipamos uma
tendência um treino da psicologia hoje
em dia por cirurgia positiva taça
manifestar como como uma expressão
bastante significativa ou aaa a 11 anos
atrás não era o otimismo 21 livros o
otimismo
vamos um pouco é esta esta ideia de
entre um copo mas saiu um copo meio
vazio é a resposta mais óbvia é é
preferível ver o copo meio cheio mas
outra coisa que também é outra
consequência pragmática e de desta
quinta-feira do copo desta energia é
ideia que o corpo pode ir enchendo gota
a gota que escanear naturalmente que as
grandes funções e os grandes projectos
possam e portanto naturalmente tem
espaço e devem ter espaço nas vidas
individuais na vida coletiva
mas o dia a via que é decisivo tanto a
gota a gota para ir enchendo o copo
pequenas vitórias porque nas funções
junto estão muito ligadas com esta essa
capacidade aumentará nossa qualidade de
vida e isso é tão importante que o outro
de uma galinha é nessa pressa explorava
nossa batido com o carro nas traseiras
do outro parceiro de condução que no
outro carro à frente aí ela começou
exatamente naquele momento de pensar na
minha vida mas graça solucionar todas as
coisas horríveis que tinham acontecido
não só naquele dia como última semana
nos últimos dez anos e ficou cega a
criança falando tanto em cerveja que
consegue não
do acidente mas que consegue foi incapaz
de ver que o condutor do veículo da
frente no qual é submetido
era um ápice mu jovens a aliança e 70
estão daquilo que nós vemos escrever em
relação à realidade
e quanto ao otimismo ou pessimismo
depois é que o ps mesmo chega é só a
possibilidade de ver melhor
é um momento importante que tem a ver
com 11 e usufruir a usufruir o que hoje
sabemos que precisamos voltar a viver o
presente precisamos voltar a apreciar um
bom o belo eo bairro e hoje vimos aqui
em exemplos celulose pessoas que estão
com esta consciência facto que é
possível que vida e as coisas sejam
diferentes usufruir quer dizer viver
intensamente o presente é o milo dizia
também que o futuro não essa coisa tão
classe média é só voltar a ser capazes
de apreciar as experiências vivenciadas
conversas os momentos do presente e
temos na água fazia usar estes dados da
investigação científica
ora am entre vira em múltiplos contextos
e criar programas direção de felicidades
está no chão empresas melhores há pouco
o frio
estamos em conjunto e trabalhar nessa
área temos estado a trabalhar com
populações que vivem em condições de
pobreza feminina experimento social e
está obrigado então a situação se a
temos vindo a trabalhar em contexto
surge por exemplo crianças que estão
entre nato e respectivas famílias e
educadores e portanto criamos aqui
alguma forma um conjunto de truques
soluções práticas dos quais se nos vemos
só deixar alguma história agora é porque
a história tem essa grande vantagem que
enquadram dá um significado pois as
prensas concretas a cada um dos momentos
quando era pequeno divino no prédio com
os meus pais ela provasse
um dos andares mais baixos vi um senhor
formado da menina da marinha era um
crime como como aquela imagem que o que
aprendi foi professora foi passada do do
avião na china um senhor vem outra forma
era interessado do pai quatro anos já
que eu sempre passava nas escadas do pv
a maneira truculenta conseguiu pintou no
espírito da maneira que em complementar
o seu poder assim então vive com gosto
estava indisposto e quatro anos no alto
na altura não se falavam mesmos neste
segmento sem fim
nos sonhos mais mais modernas como
pedofilia mas o que é facto o que é
facto é que o time volte do pinto é ea
correr pra casa o miami por cacos no pim
cumprimento de outra maneira é uma
salvação em vez de botar botox botes
pasta das minas casas
eu vivi com gosto e está bem disposto e
eu acho engraçado e as texturas que na
história fazer um enquadramento para
aquilo que nós fazemos que esta ideia de
que o metrô aumentar com sites já nos
sonhos muito abstratas muito vagas como
funcionava
mas por outro lado é intervenção a
mudança é novas são está o nível do
atual fala em 2 falou também de manhã no
ato de compra e os o que é que a mulher
clã fundamental esta ideia de intervir
ou na ao nível do ato fala usufruir e eu
gosto mais do uso fluir mas pronto quero
falar das suas experiências temos sim
acho que é diferente se perguntar se os
coffee momento em que os sentiram mais
entusiasmados com vida
vou perguntar hoje o que hoje vos
anuncio é que o que faziam os canários
nas nossas memórias do dia e esse
obviamente coisas imprensa sobre as
janelas em frente à realidade todas as
coisas que nós fazemos e ligar e por as
pessoas de novo em contato em conversas
em contraste de informalidades a falar
de coisas muito importantes com pessoas
com quem nunca falaria na vida
vamos dar um exemplo no trabalho com
promoções
surpresa nos sonhos juntarmos por
exemplo uma sala é coordenador regional
do instituto associar o absurdo da
frente do centro sul
o senhor café a senhora que será ão o
rendimento mínimo
todos é conversar sobre o melhor no seu
passado e aqui o que será um show de
profundo para aquela comunidade
a roda de comida habitualmente num
contexto em que as conversas possam
fluir mas passam também a ser em redor
do positivos e que é muito importante é
a linguagem positiva estamos atrasados
linguagem positiva a conversa existem
positive citamos que mais pressa
a linguagem não descreve só a linguagem
cria por isso é que nós temos trabalhado
muito no dicionário do português
positivas tivéssemos mais tempo dá nos
algumas das definições que já temos
colhido é também trabalhar se conseguir
transformar as fraquezas em forças seja
quanto trabalhamos num call centers
jovens questão é muitas vezes áfrica
chamadas muito simples seja quando
estamos a trabalhar com pessoas que
vivem em circunstâncias difíceis vida
ser capaz de ajudar a desvendar a servir
que são cheios de virtudes e que são
heróis engenharia guaçu cosmópolis
surpreender até do conflito conjugal é
muito importante no qual é o meu
casamento vai escutar indicado mais
difícil aos 30 os primeiros trinta anos
depois mas saber surpreender no íntimo e
também no público no coletivo é
importante e sendo assim esta nem
percebi que não estava no programa
depois de avançar nas pesquisas
[Aplausos]